hey guys it's Monday july 25th I'm Mary
and you're watching gamespot news and
I'd love to tell you we don't have any
Pokemon ghost stories but we have
pokemon ghost stories at the Pokemon go
panel at comic con this weekend niantic
unveiled what each team leader looks
like behold your glorious leaders team
valor gets kundala who looks like a
badass army captain mystic gets Blanche
who looks like a badass supernatural
scientist and team instant gets spark
who looks like the long-lost pop and
lock member from NSYNC regardless the
panel also discussed some other features
niantic is thinking about bringing two
Pokemon go to be clear these are under
consideration so they're not even
confirmed among them was Pokemon centers
which are supposed to heal in store
pokemons in the core games we have no
idea what function it will actually
serve in Pokemon go on the subject of
trading niantic said they need the
Pokemon go servers to stabilize before
they can introduce the ability to swap
monsters so it could be a long long time
until then you can continue to turn your
unwanted Pokemon into fodder for the
ones that you do want striving to be the
very best also announced at comic-con
was the sonic game everybody wanted a
reimagining of those original Genesis
games thank you and they also announced
some crappy new one to celebrate the
blue hedgehogs 25th anniversary to Sonic
games were announced at comic-con the
first re-imagines iconic levels from
sonics past the second is an untitled
game that stars classic and modern
versions of sonic in a new adventure
against Eggman the one you want to know
about sonic mania that's the 2d
platformer that features visuals and
gameplay reminiscent of classic genesis
games it revamps zones and acts from
Sonic the Hedgehog yes Sonic the
Hedgehog 2 yes yes sonic CD sure sonic
the hedgehog 3 yes yes yes and Sonic and
Knuckles that's fine in addition
introducing new ones into the fold
players who attended the sonic party
have the opportunity to try it for
themselves so we know it's real the
second announcement was the new
adventure helm by sonic team that
features both classic and modern
versions of Sonic much like 2011's sonic
generations we don't know much else but
we do know it's coming holiday 2017 ps4
xbox one and
NX finally do you have playstation plus
it doesn't matter you don't need it to
play no man's sky no man's sky can
technically be played online but it
won't require a PlayStation Plus
subscription on ps4 in order to do so so
when you confirmed this with Game
Informer with a spokesperson saying PS
Plus won't be a requirement to play
online however you will need to be
connected to the internet for your
discoveries to register with the
universal Atlas the Atlas they're
referring to is kind of like a
compendium that all players contribute
to by being the first to discover
planets life forms and so on which they
can then name so look forward to
fantastic names like Saturn nipple
galaxy hungry hungry hippo STD better
than Jupiter second planet bacon planet
monkey butt island and more given how
incredibly vast no man's sky galaxy is
your all but guaranteed to be the first
person to ever explore most planets and
even though the game is played in a
shared world online because it's so damn
big you're unlikely to stumble upon
other players in your travels including
your friends but hopefully you'll find
some trail of their existence when you
stumble across douche planet so that's
all I have for you today but I'll see
you again tomorrow and the rest of this
week we're doing the news in America the
whole week so you got me and I'll see
you again tomorrow
perfect all bad shock what can we we
need to do it again what who Jim what oh
all right you know you know what you did
cut damn it